So, let's do a quiz on the relative merits of processor performance, power,
weight, and cost. We will have several processor models with
the relative performance, expected battery life, weight
of the overall computer, and the cost of the processor. The
question for you is, which one of these will be the worst for laptops.
The first model is the CRAWLIUM. There's very
little performance, very long battery life, extremely light,
and dirt cheap. The next model is the
SLOWIUM. It has much more performance, half the
battery life, however. It's still very light, but
it's four times as heavy as the CRAWLIUM.
And about three times more expensive. Then we
have our LAPTIUM processor. It has twice the performance
of the SLOWIUM, five hours of battery life. It's twice as heavy as the SLOWIUMN,
costS about $100. Then we have the FASTIUM,
which has more performance, significantly less battery life,
however. It's about one pound in weight, cost
$200 for the processor. Then we have the
HOTIUM at more performance, 15 minute battery life,
3 pounds and $500 and the BURNIUM processor,
double the performance of the HOTIUM, its
battery lasts 2 minutes, it's 20 pounds in
weight and costs $5,000. So, which one of
these would you least want in your laptop.